It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us today for our 163rd episode!
Thank you!
Thank you all Ruffians!
Before we know it, we'll be at our next milestone too here!
BAU BAU!
Well, for those who are joining us today for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short, fun morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And definitely once a week.
Yes, temporarily once a week.
But it's also hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you, yes, temporarily on Mondays once a week.
You know, so then we can get a bit more balance in our lives right now.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Yes!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
It's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
I've been watching you for a long time!
Thank you, BAU BAU!
The best way to start the day!
Yeah!
So Minecraft and the FUWAMOCO Morning!
But you know!
What?
Well, a brand new week is here!
So now, it's our job to start the day off on the right paw!
Right, FUWAMOCO!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO-chan, you waited up the week.
Doesn't look like a rough one.
Wow.
Wow?
It's a fun weekend, though, right?
Yeah.
Like, Ruffians, it's a fun weekend, right?
It's your birthday today!
FUWAMOCO, HAPPY BIRTHDAY!
Man, I'm really sorry that I have following news for you.
Huh?
On your birthday, too.
Oh, birthday.
Of all the days!
There's nothing nasty, so don't think- Moco-chan?
There's been a Pero sighting.
Oh, but not on the birthday!
I'm sorry, but it's important information.
Maybe it'll be like another Pero cake!
You know, I thought it was a Pero sighting, but it was a very cute- That would be appropriate!
Maybe not.
We don't know, but it's a feeling.
Let's take a look at what Pero looks like at this time.
Let's take a look.
De-den!
That is not a cheek.
What are we looking at?
I don't know, this is just... Woah, there's a Pero, a cat, and a very suspiciously small crow out there.
I mean, the cat is super cute.
Yeah, very very cute.
There's just lots of other, you know, sightings.
Nasty things going on.
Yeah, I don't know, just looking at this I feel worried.
What do you think is going on?
I feel anxious about the future.
What is happening to you?
It's way deep.
Yeah, why is the clown so smug?
Why does he look like that?
I know.
Is he friends with Pero?
Is that why he's smiling?
I think it looks like he likes his job.
That's good, but... I don't know.
I feel like maybe he likes his job, but he's a bit... Moco-chan, did you notice one thing you know?
Pero smiling.
Clown smiling.
Cat smiling.
Yeah.
Is the cat gonna be okay?
I got nightmares!
I don't know if FUWAMOCO is dead, I don't know if the cat would be okay, but I think... The clown and Pero maybe.
Nightmares?
But maybe.
This is too many questions.
I think Ruffians, you know in this situation where no matter how much you look at it and try to analyze it, you just don't understand.
You're supposed to just turn around.
What did you say?
If you don't understand.
Don't understand?
Yeah, if you don't understand.
Don't understand it?
Turn around!
Don't look at my- Don't understand?
BAU BAU!
Agreed.
Balloons for birthday!
Balloons also for the start of a new week, but birthday.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, speaking of birthday.
BIRTHDAYS!
There was a birthday over the weekend!
There's a bunch of birthdays, but one in particular.
Yes!
It was Hajime!
BOOM BOOM BOOM!
FUWAMOCO!
A week was his very first birthday!
Happy Birthday!
And guess what?
FUWAMOCO!
We were guests too!
BAU BAU!
We were part of the Otamayo Medley!
And Biboo was there too!
I'm Koseki Bijou!
We were cool right?
And we did the heart-to-massage!
Heart-to-massage!
With Hajime!
You really brought me back to hololive!
Have a howl of a day too!
Biboo talks too!
It's been a little while!
Just so you know, Advent, we still shouldn't sing it together.
BAU BAU, but you know, we got to see Hajime's amazing dancing all throughout the 3D Birthday!
And also a new song, too!
Please check it out, okay, Advent?
You have to check it out!
Okay!
I thought it was a very, very, uh, what's it?
Emotional.
Like, I was really touched even though I saw Hajime talking about how this was Hajime's very first time one!
That's what the live was deemed as.
You know what Hajime always dreamed about?
If he ever had, you know, their own event, they could've won it.
So, you know, finally she's able to be the star of the show!
First starring role!
Yes, very important.
I feel like I very much understand her feelings all now.
Yeah, so we're happy to be a part of the show.
Happy birthday Hajime!
BAU BAU!
Because of our celebrations,
I know I'm evolving.
Well, it's June!
I feel like maybe this sort of, you know, um, snuck up on a bunch of Ruffians!
Yeah, but you don't!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's that time of year!
Too bright even!
Too bright voice patch!
And now available on the hololive official shop!
Great downloadable GGM paws!
And I have a very cute Shiori!
No shipping!
Nothing!
And you know, GG already just made!
FUWAMOCO Wedding is very cute!
We have two of our voices on sale!
You can listen to them in English, Japanese, and you can also take a listen to the sound after the story.
Ruffians, you know you can listen to the sample on the website when you don't need to because I don't really want you to.
It's just, um... Embarrassing!
Don't go and listen to it, okay?
I feel like the Ruffians very much enjoy the June Bright season, huh?
Because you know, it's the first time we're viewing.
And you know, this time, I know Ruffians maybe last year you know we had a little bit different wedding and everything, you know.
But this time!
This time, in case it wasn't obvious, the scenarios are different!
So, please check them out, you know?
You can sort of get to see... Fuwawa!
Seeing flowers together with Fuwawa and maybe after... I'm about to marry you.
After getting groceries together with Fuwawa!
Yeah!
It's a golden...
Also come home to Moco-chan there!
Hi!
Yeah, maybe, no, Moco-chan.
You might come take a look at your wedding dress.
No!
You know that you can't look at the wedding dress before, right?
It should be common knowledge, huh?
It's a common knowledge!
It should be common knowledge!
Last year was amazing!
Well then you have to check out this year's too!
This year there's an after story.
Which are in both English and Japanese as well.
Please check them out.
It's a little bit of a doki doki kind of time of year, but please check them out.
Unfortunately, or fortunately, they're only on sale until September 29th!
They are limited.
It may be hard to understand, but they are limited!
But, you know, so... We put our hearts into them, so... Powerful.
Yeah.
So you have a few months, okay.
Is it the same story for both English and Japanese?
It is, I'm sure.
It might be a bit of a different story.
A little bit of a different feeling.
It's up to you, you know.
I'm sure.
Please take it all, okay?
Why are digital goods limited?
It's up to you, maybe.
Maybe there's another one next year, because this one's in 2025.
Maybe, I don't know.
I don't know, that's my thought.
Your theory.
My theory, that's why.
Yeah.
No, I think it's just because there'll be another one maybe again, eventually.
Maybe another wedding.
Maybe, you know, that's the thing is, you know, nothing is ever...
There's people that just like having weddings a lot, right?
So they have weddings one year and another year, right?
Are there people like that?
I guess we're like that, huh, Moco-chan?
Are we doing the bow?
Oh, like that!
Is that what it's called?
They just have a wedding for fun.
Yeah, I know.
It's beautiful.
I've never heard of that.
I guess FUWAMOCO, we're like that, huh?
Every June.
All the hololive members, every June.
It's June Brite season.
Don't forget.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, and no shipping.
Direct into your paws.
We have some other happy things to happen!
This is the second FUWAMOCO Morning in a row that we get to share this role!
We must be jealous!
Well, we finished another game!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
We said goodbye to Fatal Frame!
Yeah!
We finished a PS2 game that we've been playing!
The classic one!
Yeah, you know...
We're trying to find our big brother, Malfoy!
He's in the scary Himuro Mansion!
We went in there and then we found out the story about the rope shrine priestess!
Yeah, the meeting.
Her sadness.
You know, we have mom's camera, the mystical, suspicious, crazy crown camera!
You know, it pointed and drives the ghosts away, but it's very scary!
We finally found our brother!
And he said, no, I'm gonna stay with the crazy, crazy giant maiden I just met.
Goodbye.
Haa!
BAU BAU yo!
What about your little sister, HAI?
More shocking than that though.
You know, Moco-chan kept on reloading at the end of a boss fight being like, is that good enough?
Did I use too many healing items?
Did I do well enough to get lots of points?
You only get so many healing items.
Only to find out that the final battles... If you get hit by the boss, you're dead.
There's no use for healing items!
Moco-chan!
All our healing items!
All the restarts!
All the worry and anxiety!
About not having items when we need it at the end of the game!
Ruffians!
You should've told me.
It's your fault, officially.
It's because I tingle!
Because I tingle!
It's okay!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, yes, demon dog.
Nightmare mode is not happening.
But there is still more Fatal Frame games!
Like Fatal Frame 2 on PS2 as well!
So maybe one day we'll get to play that too huh?
We'll have to see!
Stick around!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
Yeah we're gaming demon dogs!
Speaking of games...
Catch the big game last night.
The big game, Moco-chan.
Because hololive is coming back to the Dodgers!
There's another hololive night happening in Los Angeles Dodgers!
Dodgers Stadium.
Yeah, Dodgers Stadium.
A second time in the last year was the first hololive night with the Dodgers.
And it's back this year.
It's gonna be taking place on July 5th.
2025!
It's here, yes!
It's here!
Very soon!
Just in case you don't know because I get coffee still.
It's less than a month.
But it starts at 4.15pm!
That time at the Dodgers Stadium!
At the Dodgers' home!
It's nice!
And you know, there'll be lots of fun stuff including... Guess what?
Martindale!
But it's different though, it's the Dodgers' home!
And then also, apparently...
I saw, I saw the, the, the, you know, the report they said.
The report?
I thought like, oh my gosh, are they allowed to say all of this?
What, what, what, what?
They said, there's gonna be a single long reason of take me out to the ballgame during the 7th inning.
Oh!
Threat of the baseball game!
And I have to be there for quite a while if it's the 7th inning maybe.
All of them.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
That sounds so much fun!
So that means you can just go and have a big party on the field!
Dancing to like, you know, Kirameki Riders!
Right!
Shining Smile Story!
Yeah!
Wicked Dimensions!
Why are there spoilers?
That's too fun.
Is that allowed?
Are you allowed to go on the field?
I don't know.
That's amazing.
And then, also the ticket package includes a ticket to the baseball game.
That makes sense.
That's an event exclusive Dodgers X hololive Trading Card.
Ruffians, what are we gonna do, huh?
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
But it sounds like a super big party!
A real hololive night at the dodges!
So we hope for maybe any Ruffians hololive fans who are really into baseball!
That you have a bunch of fun there!
Or you know, you have baseball friends!
You can be like, well, your hobby, my hobby, let's have fun!
Yeah, we could wait maybe to get your friends into hololive too, huh?
Or get you into baseball.
I'm looking forward to it!
I'm excited!
I don't understand baseball, but we like throwing the ball and chasing the ball.
We're very competitive like that.
But we're super excited and so still!
Go hololive go!
And dodges.
Go dodge your eyes!
BAU BAU!
Just hit the ball and run.
I think so, but then what if you have to go to the base?
And then if they hit you, they're gonna punch you with the ball and then you're like, ouch!
You're out!
You're out of there!
Yeah, but then what if you know you're out in the field and the ball comes your way and you have the glove on and you have to catch it and then- Where do you throw it?!
It hits it with the baseball bat.
And then you catch it in your glove, they're out.
Yeah.
But what if you catch the ball and you know, then you gotta toss it to someone who you're tossing to.
I don't get it.
There's too much stress!
Everybody's watching the ball!
All I know is that I'm very, very good
At hitting foul balls.
Good job, Moco-chan.
Take the ball, don't give it back!
It's your ball now!
And then you can go and take it to Biboo and be like, Biboo, can you sign this?
Good plan.
And then I'll just trade the ball for the signed trading card.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO, you also had some other milestones happen yesterday!
Some of the cover songs have hit some big milestones!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We have!
Identity!
Our cover of Identity!
It's a song we first released back on 20!
Good 20!
You know, we kind of wanted to be able to sing this song to be able to talk about our identity as fans!
You know, and now it's hit 2 million!
Thank you so much for helping!
I hope you enjoy listening to it and maybe you've heard it before.
Maybe you haven't heard it before.
Please go check it out and make us really, really happy.
But!
Next!
Cute na Kanojo!
Maybe this is the spookiest song covered by us.
We released it for Halloween.
And actually there's two different versions.
Three different versions.
We have FUWAMOCO together!
And then also FUWARASOLO and MOCOCHAN SOLO!
So you can kinda see all different versions of what we sing in like solo!
And thanks to your Ruffians, it hit 1.5 million!
Thank you!
You know, it doesn't have to be Halloween to listen to it though, you know?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yeah!
We released our very first Halloween after we debuted!
The English version of Koyoiwa Halloween Night hololive song!
Nerissa!
She did the English lyrics and we sung it all together!
It's such good memories.
It's still the best version!
Thank you!
I think maybe, you know, many Adventrix don't really know about it.
We'll definitely give it a good listen!
You can hear it over on the official hololive English channel!
And thanks to you, it reached 1 million views!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
I really like being able to sing the whole, like, you know, idol songs all together in English.
It's funny, I feel like nowadays you don't really hear them.
Right!
I feel like you know, especially you hear that they can engage, like holo-cute, but otherwise they're not really sung that often.
And it's a shame!
They're good!
They're so good and special!
Lots of memories!
You haven't listened to it?
You should go for it then!
It's very spooky but also very cute too.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for listening to them lots and lots!
FUWAMOCO, we really do love singing and music and being able to express ourselves this way, so we hope to continue to be able to sing lots and lots!
And so, having you listen to our music and enjoy it and share it
Really kind words with us, it means a lot.
It's really important.
So thank you so much!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And!
Yeah, just moments ago, a new event is happening!
Yes!
It's the whole live!
Minecraft Gold Rush Survival!
It just happened!
Botan-senpai is organizing it!
And you know in a special server, Botan-senpai, she created money.
She created money.
To pick a job and make money.
So we've been doing just that!
It's very interesting from the beginning.
We have a bunch of different job classes we can pick.
We can pick the sports, minor, primary.
FUWAMOCO!
We decided, right?
Exploring!
Yeah, and we've had some pretty good success.
I feel like we thought we succeeded pretty well and then I don't think we have.
Well, we got a big water medal.
And that means that's worth a hundred thousand gold.
Well, see, you know, when you get money, you have the money in your pocket, but you can't really do anything with it.
So, and if you die, then you lose half of it.
So, you have to make sure... What we did was we invested in the stocks.
Invested in the stocks.
And then we had some good luck.
We had some good luck.
We bought low and sold high.
So then we were like, what do we do now?
Because now Moco-chan has over 100,000 money.
It's my money too, so that's 10,000 of my money.
So then we bought a big white metal.
And we can keep it.
Yeah.
Cuz that is a money.
And now we won't lose it, right Moco-chan?
No!
Which is good because I've died a couple times because Moco-chan leaves me to die.
I'm not!
But the source of this money, Moco-chan, where was it from?
It was from Yagoro-san.
Yagoro-san likes to show up randomly.
Big world Yagoro-san.
And we helped him to find a bunch of them.
Like maybe... Altogether.
I feel like at least a dozen.
Six?
A dozen, yeah.
And so, we made one.
Thanks to Yakko-san.
But it definitely was quite a bit of a frenzy, huh?
It's a bit of a frenzy!
Yakko-san also makes a very scary sound when he dies.
FUWAMOCO!
But you really don't know what's gonna happen.
Who's gonna be the richest at the end of this?
You know there's a bunch of mini-games.
Delimited events are happening too.
So we're gonna do our best!
And see just how much money we can make together.
Although I don't know, Moco-chan.
Is it okay for us to be together as a team?
Yeah.
Team.
I guess you know you can just ask others to do quests and stuff for you, right?
So... I didn't realize there was quests.
Thank you.
BAU BAU!
I don't know you at all.
It's a little bit of a rough start with that Pero Sighting, but I have a good feeling about this week, huh?
What do you think, Ruffians?
Are you still not quite feeling it yet?
A little bit more... Nina Pup Talk.
Moco-chan, can you share some kind words with us?
Okay, here I go!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
Sometimes, I know it's hard to deal with the punchy life you'll feel.
Sometimes, your armor is stronger.
And other, it's like it's not even there.
I think the best thing we can do in situations like that where you feel overwhelmed, where you feel like you might do or say something you regret...
You know, just take a deep breath.
Try to look at the situation.
And try to take a small break from things and come back to it when you're refreshed.
You know, your armor is stronger.
I know you can do it.
So keep working towards your passions!
But remember to take a break if things are not feeling like, you know, like they usually do.
Okay!
You're amazing so keep at it!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Keep at it, okay, Ruffians?
But you know when you're feeling a little bit off, like something's off, it's a little bit different than usual.
Please take a rest, okay?
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at some of the regular questions from the Ruffians today!
We have a Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... It's Winnie!
I thought you were gonna say that Winnie turned 26.
But you know, Winnie could be 26.
Happy birthday Winnie!
Good job.
How does Winnie bow bye?
Can Winnie maybe eat a piece of a toy?
BAU BAU!
Hot.
Very cute, but a little bit... really hot.
BAU BAU!
You know, Winnie's very special puppy has been there with you forever!
Almost 26 years.
Almost, yeah.
We're so happy to hear that you've made such a great change in your life.
I know.
I think it's very obvious here, but you have a very powerful, powerful... I know.
Keeping your heart happy.
Nice and warm.
And also a lovable buddy, too!
Yes!
We hope that you enjoy many cuddles together from here on.
Okay!
Lots and lots, okay?
BAU BAU!
And... Oh!
For our next corner.
For today, I went on a walk.
We have...
FUWAMOCO Day!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Ruffians!
Look at the weather!
FUWAMOCO But!
FUWAMOCO Weather not the trees!
FUWAMOCO Trees!
FUWAMOCO These are some of the oldest living things on the planet.
FUWAMOCO That's why I like to look at them.
Moco-chan.
The twins!
Top twins!
Twins!
Yeah!
Top twins!
Are we top twins too?
Yeah, maybe not that tall.
Not that tall, but... You know, we've been around for a while too.
How many people tall is that?
Maybe you can count them by like average twins.
What?
I could probably count them by average tree height.
I think it's probably at least 5 people tall.
That's my estimate.
I think it's much more.
How many then?
Estimate.
I don't need to, it's tall.
Yes.
5.
Yes!
But you don't have to do that.
They've made it much, much better for you.
Yes!
Please give them a hug.
Unless you're not allowed to.
Oh.
If you're not allowed, don't give them a hug.
At least ask first.
But you know, we hope that we can make a difference by protecting your smile too.
So we'll continue to work hard.
We're not a tweed though.
We're demon dogs.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sticking with us on YouTube!
And we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... This!
How did you both feel when you first learned about the sneeze counter?
Does it bother you now or compared to when you first learned about it?
Did your feelings change when Fuwawa's sneezes started to be counted?
I've been a Ruffian for a year and I'm confused by it.
Confused?
It makes us to be a little bit confused.
You know, especially at first.
And you know, there's not really any explanation or anything.
Not everybody has the same calendar.
It's only natural to count.
Multiple five.
But you know, it's just something very silly that the Ruffians have made for us.
You know, and it makes us really happy and smile a lot that the Ruffians that you want
To celebrate every sneeze of ours!
Yeah!
Especially when there's so many!
I feel like they're more rare nowadays.
Oh, maybe that's for you, Moco-chan.
But my sneezes have been counted from the very beginning, too!
I just sneezed at a much slower rate than Moco-chan.
600 going strong!
I just passed 100!
600!
Yeah!
Almost, almost, and not quite, Moco-chan.
Don't get ahead of yourself.
What was my best record for one stream?
I think 23?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Silly Ruffians.
Sneeze taxi.
Sneeze counting is not weird.
It's not weird!
It's silly just like us.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
20 minutes stream sounds rough.
It was very rough.
It wasn't like 8 hours or anything either.
3?
23 and a half?
How many hours?
Yeah.
4 hours maybe.
Maximum.
Minecraft makes you pretty sneezy and sleepy too, I guess.
Hi!
See, be sneezy and snoozing.
Sneezy, snoozy, hi.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the questions, Ruffians!
You know, it makes us really happy to be able to get questions of all different types, you know?
I think some Ruffians are like, oh but has this question already been asked?
Hashtag FWMCMorning.
As well as your Doggie of the Day.
Pero Sighting.
Walks.
Please share your life with us, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning is something we make together, and now, temporarily!
It's me time of week, so we're always waiting, okay?
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And next!
Our next stream!
Oh, but you know!
Oh, what's the next stream?
Our next stream is... De-den!
The BAU BAU T-shirt!
Oh, what could this be?
We're making BAU BAU!
Yeah!
BAU BAU tea!
Tapioca!
You should know we're very good at being baristas.
We are!
And I'm looking forward to running our own T-shirt!
Yeah!
Apparently it gets scary, but you know... Businesses, you know!
Running a business is a risk!
Financial risk!
It can be pretty scary!
Pretty risky!
You know, boba is delicious, but if you drink too much of it, it's not that good for you!
You need vitamins!
Also, choking hazard.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
But, you know, we're running a business.
We're gonna be focusing on making sure that our bubble tea, our boba, is the most delicious for our customers.
We're not gonna be drinking any, right, Moco-chan?
No.
So we hope that we can make you proud, Ruffians.
And that you also share your favorite bubble tea flavors with us.
Ruffians, what's your favorite?
I wanna hear it now.
It's either milk tea or taro.
It's always that.
Matcha.
You've never had it.
What?
Taro Taro's yummy.
The purple potatoes.
Cookies and cream.
Mocha.
Well, if a lot of Ruffians haven't had... Well, boba tea.
Boba tea then.
We're just gonna have to make it!
BAU BAU!
And that will be later today, so at 6pm PT.
But let's take a look at our schedule!
Our schedule!
Brand new!
De-den!
It's a little busy, busy, busy, busy week.
A little bit of a busy week.
We're gonna be doing some more of the Gold Rush Survival Minecraft.
And then, on Tuesday at 6pm, we'll be doing some more chatting and super chat reading together, Ruffians.
Wednesday, we're back early morning at 5am PT.
This time, this day is a little bit later earlier.
Depends on your perspective than usual.
It starts at 5am PT.
We're back doing some more Minecraft making money.
And then later at 6pm PT, together with Biboo and Shiori, we're playing Elden Ring Nightmare.
Our first time ever Elden Ring.
I don't know if this counts.
I don't know.
Does it count?
People are like, let's play Nightmare.
Like, okay!
So we're gonna do our best.
We're gonna make you proud.
And we're gonna ask people all the questions.
So many questions that maybe some people are like,
Hi.
First time ever meeting Ruff.
But it'll be fun because we'll be all together.
With a cute boy too.
And on Thursday we have a bit of a recording day.
But we're back on Friday morning at 3am PT for the finale of the Gold Rush Survival.
I guess that day is the last day.
The richest will be crowned with the crown of the richest.
Wow.
At 6pm!
6pm!
At 5pm PT we're gonna be playing Fatal Frame 2!
Yeah!
Fatal Frame 2!
It's here!
I know there's so many Ruffians have looked forward to it but we're gonna be starting it off.
It's a bit of a different story from the previous Fatal Frame so if you didn't catch Fatal Frame you're like, I don't know the story though!
I'm late!
Don't worry because it's standalone I think.
And apparently the main character
These are twin sisters!
So let's just play twin sisters.
As a pair of twin sisters.
And then on Saturday we're going to be continuing it at the same time, 5pm P.M.
I'm playing it on the PS2 too!
So enjoy the horrors of accidentally issuing the PS2 delay.
Moco-chan decides that she wants to restart and then we have to go and restart the PS2 and it makes the PS2 sounds.
BAU BAU!
And that's all day we have!
All members only stream together with the Doggy Pack.
We're continuing to play Coordinated Dimension.
It was a super fun action platform.
So many donuts, super cute, so colorful, such a great soundtrack.
Lots of love going into it.
So we're gonna play together with you Ruffians.
And then maybe do a little bit of chatting together too.
Thank you!
That's our brand new week coming up!
A lot of things to look forward to!
We'll do our best to care!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU Ball Game!
BAU BAU!
I got scared.
Thank you so much for being such a nice day for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Black Redwing!
BAU BAU!
Skycap!
Captain IDK!
BAU BAU!
Burton Jonathan!
Birdo!
BAU BAU!
Daishama!
Triton!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
Stay home!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
Are you laughing at me?
Yes.
BAU BAU!